their last eight threes so maybe getting
back downhill find that guy
oh boy that did not look good
anthony davis
is writhing in pain and grabbing his
lower
right leg
that was a bad landing
[Music]
[Applause]
anthony davis being tended to by the
athletic training staff
welcome back everyone to crypto.com
arena as
the gurney comes out for anthony davis
with three minutes to go in the first
half
he's up on his feet
with the aid of his teammates
deandre jordan one of them
and
that right
ankle lower leg area
turned right over
and he's as you can see unable to put
any kind of weight on it
we're going to take another look at it
right now
look at the landing right there
and
those pictures tell you why he's unable
to put any kind of weight on
[Music]
beyond
this game
certainly going to have implications for
the lakers
when you look at the fact too that he's
already missed so much time this year
typical basketball injury where you
leave the floor
and when you come down your feet don't
firmly flatly or you say
catch all of the floor it catches the
side of an
opposing player's foot so we'll take a
timeout and
hope that it's nothing that's going to
be real serious